we're gonna begin with this president
Trump planning to unveil new sanctions
against Iran later today while the u.s.
and Iran trade new threats of military
action the president said in a weekend
interview this I'm not looking for war
if there is it'll be obliteration like
you've never seen before the u.s. blames
Iran for recent attacks on oil tankers
in the Middle East which iran denies
last week arrived downed an American
drone it claims violated its airspace
while the Pentagon says the drone was
actually over international waters
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo arrived
overnight in Saudi Arabia as part of an
international campaign to put pressure
on the Middle East nation been Tracy's
at the White House Ben you sometimes
hear about red lines and certain
administration's does the president have
a red line here well not a clearly
defined one and I think that's probably
because the president is trying to give
himself some space to maneuver here as
for those sanctions the White House has
not put details out on those but they
are expected to target Iran's
Revolutionary Guard and it's atomic
agency meanwhile the president is still
talking quite tough I'm not looking for
war and if there is it'll be
obliteration like you've never seen
before President Trump likes to taunt
but says he actually prefers to talk
offering to meet Iran's supreme leader
without preconditions except for this
one you can't have nuclear weapons and
if you want to talk about it good
otherwise you can live in a shattered
economy for a long time to come despite
calling off a military strike last week
CBS News has learned the President did
approve a cyber strike on Iranian
computer systems for rocket and missile
launches but mr. Trump acknowledges that
some in his administration won an even
tougher response including national
security advisor John Bolton who issued
this warning Sunday neither Iran nor any
other hostile actor should mistake u.s.
prudence and discretion for weakness
Iran is vowing to increase its stockpile
of enriched uranium and could as early
as this week exceed the limits created
by the nuclear deal president Trump
pulled out of last year the president
we want a brighter future for the people
of the Islamic Republic of Iran the
administration's strategy is unclear
besides strangling Iran's economy with
sanctions in hopes of getting a better
deal we'll call it
let's make Quran great again for their
part Democrats are now accusing the
president of trying to solve a crisis of
his own making meanwhile overnight Iran
says those cyberattacks against it did
not work and they warned that they could
shoot down another US drone Anthony Ben
thank you